why just say it when you can spray it
this is the Aston Martin Showroom on
Park Lane in central London targeted by
just stop oil activists campaigning
against fossil fuel licensing and
production
it was their latest Act of vandalism in
the name of environmental campaigning
here they are throwing soup at a Vincent
van Gogh painting
the government know corporations no over
350 protesters have been arrested in
London this month
they were sending a message directly to
the Home Secretary
she wants to introduce new rules to
crack down on protests if they threaten
Public Safety or could or could serious
disruption no you can't just start a
riot or glue yourself to the roads and
get away with it
bodies like Transport for London can
already apply for court injunctions to
stop demonstrations but swella bravman
wants her and other secretaries of state
to also have that power these people are
turning up being arrested and coming
back out on the street the next day the
current legal process that police have
to follow doesn't give them sufficient
powers to stop this happening rather
than while Aston Martin was being spray
painted other environmental activists
held this demonstration just across the
road in Hyde Park this event is not
designed to cause the disruption often
associated with Extinction Rebellion
although that kind of protest has become
their brand the people I've spoken to
here say that even if the government
changes the law they won't stay home or
change their tactics blocking traffic is
disruptive and nobody wants none of us
want to be disruptive like I said we're
not doing this because it's fun
but what is going to be way more
disruptive are the effects of climate
breakdown
Paul Stevens a member of Extinction
Rebellion also served in the
metropolitan police for over 30 years he
says this new bill is totally
unreasonable because it punishes
non-violent protesters that is Draconian
absolute Draconian power the the
government we've got now is to the right
of bolsonaro and to the right of the
fascist government we've got in Italy I
mean if people have to wake up and see
what's happening
the public order bill will be put to MPS
next week it also proposes jailing
protesters who glue themselves to roads
for up to six months it's a penalty lots
of activists would be willing to face
leaving many asking why the government
is going ahead with it Becky Cottrell
Sky News